any playoff where if I can kiddo I
that's right you want a playoff series
fine yeah fine fine Oh Oh finally Kate
Leonard is doing his thing and he's
gonna leave us you know what's funny
that's obviously the the thought
sometimes this kind of level of success
you know what people always
underestimate is people falling in love
with a city trailer strategy is I'm
gonna go play for the Clippers but then
all of a sudden you live there for a
year you know I don't know his like if
he's married or versed there you go
right all of a sudden wife makes the
best friend of her life she starts
chirping like you just never know you
never like there's so many bet I mean it
happened with Paul George in Oklahoma
City yeah oh she should be a pit stop
and he was gonna go to LA and what
happened was he fell in love with it I
know I'm getting a little sports nerdy
sorry oh yes we have a we only know our
team's how well what about the Leafs
devastating
do you hate Boston - oh wow my husband's
from Boston so I don't know I'm not like
definitely Boston yeah oh is that right
yeah it's awesome having a Matt Matt
helped us make the game makes a ton of
sense yeah coming together well at least
the game part yeah actually think I do
the colouring thing but like the game
part now yeah he came to us just like
that she's got a he's such a nice guy
it's like God you guys need the best guy
yeah he's the best colouring boy yeah
he beats Kevin I love us more me razzing
him because Kevin Kevin's actually my
real real good 3/12 everybody it's gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 312
I've been slumming that I flubbed it
yesterday this is episode 312 of the
askgaryvee show and it's exciting one
because we're drinking wine playing
games and based on what's happened in
the first two minutes you're off screen
the energy is real the one plus one
equals 11 here is very real with these
two lovely ladies and ladies why don't
you tell the Vayner nation who you are
and what you're about oh I like this
okay I'm Matt I'm cat and that's cat we
cannot we have seven children between
the two of us I mean what was one of six
and the other have one yes imagine yeah
I got six no three or four very
important yes but they're one you know I
mean they won't you together uh and we
sir will there be an eighth
there should be but we need a donor
because husbands done but I'm ready to
get yeah really yeah we think about
having a baby together
me I don't know how to make it happy you
need are you available
oh you that's so cute
oh yeah what's your thumb that that
would be fine we can we can flog it we
can have a new show and promotion for
empathy yeah babies always sell wine
puppies we can get a dog and a baby
seven children yeah seven children and I
mean we give the spiel of the human side
and then we have a business side what
side you want business or human me
business you business okay the business
what I mean though we give the business
side of human so what you guys actually
like everybody here is like just getting
to know you okay you're already on third
base all right come back to first base
so we created we created a business
through a need that we we were looking
for we wanted a place where moms could
come together in a non-judgmental place
where it could be positive and fun and
there was nothing in our city at the
time physically physically we did
physically created I wanted for an event
club in Toronto we brought together
women unfortunately interesting yeah
very interesting when we wine and we
have no babies
so with wine it was always with wine and
without children so you could have a
conversation you know like these old
dudes have like the Elks Club yeah we're
did a young woman Club we can hang [ __ ]
on our husbands yeah loose and live yes
a conversation because when where babies
are there your brain it's like rattle
right because you're actually on paying
attention so they don't choke yeah yeah
we need it to sell tickets because moms
are flaky don't get mad but they are so
they're like if they have the best
intentions to go out and then come five
o'clock they're like [ __ ] the B I see
so in real life because I've seen this
right like if you're just getting
together with your friends inevitably
like oh yeah Lolita was we're gonna get
together we got some wine ketchup and
then it's two and a half yes oh so we're
like half of somebody comes they have to
rush out yeah absolutely so we're like
charge them make them show up get them
out of the house we thought we were
winning cuz we made like a hundred
dollars and we were like we are huh we
are to stay at home mom's right taking
moms happy and they felt like they had a
place to belong we were like Oh worst
nights over you look at each other
you're like we had fun and we made a
hundred bucks yeah weird
yeah guess who didn't say that
who the husband why what do they say 100
bucks you you didn't just go there for
an hour and have a good time you took
all that time to plan the event get the
sponsors get the speakers you know who's
always wrong the husband's the husband
yeah I like that you please say that
because so many women know know so many
women oh this is my single most viral
clip ever save it it's like when I post
this on interview husbands are hunting
us wrong this is gonna go viral as funny
women are gonna love you women say to us
I have a passion I have a hobby but it
doesn't pay and I'm like does it give
you something outside of the house and
that if there is you there is nothing
more devastating to me in the world of
entrepreneurship then wives who have
ideas yeah who then first go to their
husband yep and their husbands shoot it
down out of one truth yes the husband's
insecure deep in the soul of a husband
is an insecurity that if god forbid my
wife goes and does this and she makes
more money than me and in that in our
world there are so many ideas by women
today that will never see the day of
life because the woman is also insecure
and when she gets the negative feedback
she shelves it yeah it's double
insecurity and we need to make a call of
action right now that women need to see
through their ideas when their inner yes
the only thing that really helped for us
to I think and we is that we had each
other and we gave each other the
confidence to keep going even if
everyone around us was telling it was
not like we say we had a quote in our
last podcast that was like we had if
there was a brick wall a tornado a
hurricane of fire another brick wall we
had to go around that over that because
we could seven children at home and no
child care so we could not actually
leave until someone came home which was
our husband's on their clock and then we
could leave so we had to find a way to
make an income to even leave to pay a
babysitter in order to pursue that we
helped a shine oh by the way I know by
the way this is important this is why
your story's so important I'm
super-pumped hearing this and so and so
is a version for everybody yeah you know
like when people like this level of like
people are entitled to success as a
problem somebody hit me up the other day
Gary you talk about working for free or
like working for nothing like how do I
do that living in the Bay Area I'm like
move dick yeah yeah I like I'd like Gary
you can't do what you're saying I live
in Bushwick I'm like move to deep deep
deep Long Island yeah yeah yeah and
that's another thing is that we never
wanted we never wanted to take money
from every what and people are like get
investors you can oh my god go to the
bank
we're gonna make money no I learnt the
[ __ ] Google algorithms the worm the
crawl the [ __ ] i sat there with my baby
in bed and I like what the [ __ ] is this
we learned everything on our own we hire
nobody and I think and you know I'll
tell you this year will be a
multi-million company as of we're into
our second million like as a profit you
have more than so we sput i'm when i
tell you we did not take a dime until we
made a dime we did not use a dime until
we had more than two dimes these are one
of you have an entrepreneurial spirit as
a kid like some bracelets candy so you
got kicked out of high school together
I separately you guys have known each
other since when yeah yeah okay okay
ready fun good act yes grade nine we met
we how does it go down we would use to
skip school get high get high and eat
bagels
okay so nine through me yes each other
and you're like oh we're both loser
chicks yeah yeah brunt we don't fit in
anywhere but we don't fit nothing I have
a learning disability I've never done
well at school I've always been the
rogue one so I'm sitting there I'm like
so the teacher goes to me the teachers
like oh my god no no I need to see it
look 30% don't know 30 look oh great
okay well you're really good a gym no I
know what DS dc's a there's one a what
in gym deep I got four A's in high
school all in gym
everything else is DS and apps I didn't
even get one of these like I was like
fail fail and I was a breaking my button
cam in Canada yeah you guys just did
pass and fail that no good grade oh you
did we do you know going to school in
the deal did you graduate high school no
I love you you were my favorite
haha you didn't graduate high school mom
[ __ ] fired up I'm so jealous of you I
so deeply wish I didn't graduate high
school yeah I did she didn't do
traditional no I don't have and then I
did it in night school and summer school
because it's the only way I could focus
yeah we don't have it we resent you I
just I went to work I could love I just
don't know parents think my mom was in
New York and god I have kind of a [ __ ]
up story but it's all it's on the
podcast but I went was okay it's in the
things we have it's on a book too so we
have we come we come from single moms
okay when I was a young girl my mom
lived in a cabin in the woods no
electricity no toilet no running water
or we lived you know woods baby I'm in
I'm a woods baby for a few years okay
we used to wake up in the morning stuff
papers throw papers and I'd go to school
before us we could make Nick extra
income we'd like roll quarters so we
could like get to go to the community
center for $0.50 I remember that to go
swimming so then she also is from a
single mom who's now thrown into the the
single mom world and has to go to work
so we have two moms were late on it so
that's your situations more divorce oh
[ __ ] I gotta go into the work world yeah
yeah yeah so we're sitting there and so
we've watched these women so my mom used
to always apologize because she would
work all the time around the clock right
so she eventually became as the vice
president of a bank started as like she
also didn't finish University and worked
with so I watched her now that being
said what drove us was the fact that we
never fit in but together we felt like
we had an energy that people would watch
us not talk to us they would be like
they would want to know more from us
about our experiences about what we did
and that's how it grew from the event
space was then we started to people
everywhere was like I want you to come
to my city I want you to my seat well we
can't go everywhere so how can we get to
you how can we get into your living room
and still be with Kat net we can live
stream there was no live streaming on
YouTube so we found a software to make
it happen
a year later someone else I would like
get a business plan and we're like [ __ ]
that we're just gonna go someone wanted
to sit down I'm like you need five years
I'm like I don't even know what's gonna
happen tomorrow but I know what we can
do is go from our gut and every day when
something felt right we were like that
feels right and then it was more of what
we needed and when it felt right to us
you guys stayed insular yeah my number
one thesis on this it's just life is to
stay insular yeah
that's we did but I think we have the
raw feelings from our parents to know
what feels right guys swim reason why we
wouldn't we would never take money from
anyone else because things happen
adversity is the foundation of success
yeah and you know you get confidence
by [ __ ] up honey now you get some was
there by [ __ ] failing like all that
[ __ ] you have once you get used to
everyone [ __ ] on ya yeah you can't
taste their [ __ ] yeah we we're so used
to failing it's it's like not a surprise
it's a surprise when we succeed well
yeah we're the one says yes we're like a
fox we're actually kind of no we're more
comfortable in them no no that's fun to
say but when you know honestly they are
surprised when we see that's what we're
different fair enough
we're very comfortable in a place where
no okay so you guys do this event yeah
like it goes the first one goes well
well like you get intoxication you keep
going it starts building people online
come to Chicago we can't we got seven
[ __ ] kids on you go live streaming
then we go to [ __ ] Germany we call
someone in Germany we don't actually go
we knew this was going we find a
software in Germany that they can live
stream on a website he's just a dude
like live stream wasn't a thing yet so
we're calling the German was a dude's
name it's really like been yeah okay so
Ben and I are like so we're tied go
shooting we're talking to like Japan
okay we're like so we're like this isn't
working it was glitchy we could but
we're like bucket 20 people are watching
we're like we're gonna keep going how
many better 2-0 20 right now and then
even 300 300 people are watching this
we're doing the right thing and what are
you guys doing like just drinking and
yelling okay this is a fun fact so we
people tried to put us in a space of
properness
and crafting and meals and everyone was
YouTube experts at the time like like
moms they want us to do mom they wanted
us to be mom experts so we tried it and
the camera would go off we'd like this
is we would be net bad like the [ __ ]
shitty we're good we're terrible you
weren't good at not being yourself yeah
that's right we had to learn that and
then what we did is we went to Instagram
and we started to begin to just sort of
talk about and what was the account
individually or you made a joint one
obviously everything email everything's
together word I was like who's emailing
back so matter some guys ever fight no
that's awesome by the way I asked you
that with the belief that you were gonna
actually answer that way and I actually
believed there are many there are
relationships to be had in the world
that actually have
yes you want to know why why this is
[ __ ] up are you ready he's ready so
what do you know where you are right now
where I live and [ __ ] okay so worked
I love [ __ ] we're Twin Flames yeah means
we're one soul divided into two together
for all of our lives she told him I
could be guys I'm about to start that
business I would do it to you right now
by clipping over a card with my master
asana and one with like a two-speed sub
like you're a twin [ __ ] flames bucks
at home he's a [ __ ] baby we didn't
pay her and we ended up teach him
charging her counseling friends she's
like and she's like I've never told
anybody this before but sharing
everything let me tell you something I
swear the three of us share this I
understand why that happened humans
don't understand this one unbelievable
truth when you have the courage to be a
hundred percent yourself the world will
lean into you at scale yeah but what's
happen we feel that all the time with
everyone who follows us every time we go
on tour meet these women they tell us
their secrets of course our email is
like a confessional people like cool I
have never said this but I feel like
into my DMS are so crazy like I don't
know like like it's sad if the secrets
we could tell but it's safe with us and
that's for sure so we always had to
figure out how to make money right so by
the way you need to make that a you need
to make that an Instagram like yeah what
secrets are safe with us
they are sure there's there always are
beginner bucket we don't we gain nothing
from sharing them we're never fought
yeah did you ever like the same boy no
no no we don't in high school you guys
didn't like the same boy ever no
interesting you like different types of
dudes yeah we like we're very different
bad like I'm completely not attracted to
your husband works there that's the best
thing that ever happened yeah yeah I
mean we [ __ ] the same person baby love
with the same person no no pens what how
much empathy wine you doing no we we
okay this is the truth I think because
of where we I was a social worker before
I did this okay and
I actually ended a point at Le Monde I
was I believe she was there to like
bring me back a Yoshi okay where I would
be the better stripper I know that uh so
go why don't you do it right life is
longer see the things she does on stage
yeah a little bit stripper I that's a
town give the fans what they want it to
talent
so anyways friendship is it the reason
we don't fight she was because it's so
important like what we're doing is so
important the things that people tell us
about our friendship to the resonates
with people yeah but that so now know
what you know what's amazing
like that's what's so special about the
relationship that makes sense now you
have this big thing that is but you guys
were 14 or 16 you were 18
no we 22 Inc there cuz we were just not
like motherhood boots what brought us
together because we had interesting
limits on [ __ ] up so why have your
first kiss so you guys like we're
friends in high school and then did
chatter Thea once I was like I was on
the table I liked a table dance anyways
what we do were the first step we were
the first of anyone have babies and we
were like in the like the deep dark hole
oh [ __ ] is this yes [ __ ] is this found
each other I was a social worker Isaac
this is no problem it was a [ __ ]
problem you know all those things so
that was very confusing for us and
that's how we've reconnected and never
left each other but I will tell you if
you are in a business with a partner for
us I don't know if this is a woman thing
or a partner thing but nothing is 5050
it's whoever needs more that day so
sometimes apart be good right it's so
but by the way the fact that you both
understand that yes game that that was
the biggest insight for me as I'm
getting to know you that makes it good
for you yeah you know how hard that is
for people I know kid but it's the
betterment of the person I spend my time
and in my sorors and I'm keeping you up
you'll pick me up you know what
inevitable DNA it's it's cute in theory
like hey today that sometimes that you
can last for years it's not I'm sure it
has sometimes that thing could be my
weight sometimes it's just actually me
forever listen I've been in business
partnerships with my dad and my brother
and from a pure merit of who can drive
the most revenue for the business and
this is no disrespect to my dad or my
brother I would only say it out loud
because I know they would say it out
loud as well
we'll never be my equal even though one
my dad owned a hundred percent of Wine
Library and AJ was fifty-fifty with me
at Boehner and never were they and that
and that takes my ability to be okay
with that
that takes a level of humility empathy
and true love yeah
father brother easy friends that's
incredible that you guys can do that Kat
likes to say we like we're meat you
swallow your pride swallow your balls
just well a lot of you may we have a
hard time being like we worked a lot of
men by the way let me save you time on
this for real and I know I get it but
like and women humans yes true human got
it listen wait listen please humans
right like listen one of the things I'm
very passionate about is men and women
are clearly different
that's just let's get to that boy yes
and people like have a tough time with
that I have such a tough time I can't
believe men are supposed to marry women
and Wimmers best men because we're so
different we don't see ya eye on
anything so what do you think should
happen well I just think it's we she's
yeah against this theory yeah I much
rather hang out all the time with Nate
you come and visit brother you come in
Mary having a baby I came back from
Qatar a 24 hours ago four wives three
wives
yes culture like yeah it seems insane to
us it's normal as [ __ ] what's what's it
what's insane everything's normal I you
know everything's normal Fred that
everything's from everything yeah but
everyone suppose everyone they're
supposed to marry they're supposed to do
these things yeah for us we're like I
really don't understand it like your
husband's get along or they yeah okay
mark fine I mean but they had no choice
and you know what they think you have a
choice I think you guys would have
allowed it
you guys are awesome like that could see
actually what your strength is very
obvious to me already
you would have allowed it probably
would've left them exactly listen
everything's figure out a ball no but
really they get along yes they get what
are their common interests golf I make
beliefs you know what I don't know I
think they're just respectful people to
each other that's awesome but what do
you do they have a common interest and
they make sense okay we'll see we travel
a lot but they're different interests
dudes
yes okay what are they like what's your
husband into as a dudes like what are
his hobbies or interests like sports
he's got a big into sports and playing
or watching he was a hockey player
mm-hmm he was he was in the NHL talk
about yeah I know
I know nothing I just said it your
credit for anything is everything
oh we play for a lot he got it we got
dry how many years did he play in the
NHL well he played up and down in the
NHL between minor leagues in any job
great came like all the [ __ ] I was you
know as a fighter he was an enforcer my
kids YouTube his like wow like but he's
an someone once a gentle giants this guy
on earth I never want to meet him on
night I punch people the [ __ ] mouth
that's how I am in business actually a
nice person
I just want to destroy your face yeah
and he did destroy their faces yes my
favorite thing about hockey players is
how [ __ ] up their faces yeah Barry
okay let's put that there is something
interesting about hockey players I think
the nature of hockey makes hockey
players more handsome than they are for
some I feel like oh you're so right
thank you
yeah I've been trying to figure yourself
for a long time I'm more handsome on on
a hole I believe that when you say
you're a hockey player yeah that there's
something that makes you a handsome hot
guy yeah that if that same guy yeah was
like I'm a computer programmer yeah he's
not as hot I cuz there's a status
nobody cuz you got faces get [ __ ] up
the nature of hockey unlike baseball
basketball is they all have you get the
puck hits your [ __ ] feet yeah
they fight yes it's a rugged [ __ ]
sport that's yeah there's a war there's
a rare kind of like look as we all
progress there is still animalistic
cores to our world we are still an us
agreed so a hockey player
that man is creating a little bit of
that rawness like listen you could say
anything you want about society there's
still an underlining tone about your
flight assume an punches another man in
the face there's something you like
about it
yeah we judge my friends punches ooh
[ __ ] someone I absolutely judge people
me who's Mike guys let's go very meta
we're drinking empathy wines right now
yeah this is our business right yeah
we're doing some stuff what's up how'd
you get married and we're gonna fight
YouTube that like really
really good friends no we're actually
probably like we I've been so busy
lately our friendship and Nate did a bad
job with the Jets last year and he's got
a very serious girlfriend and we've been
busy on the business I would actually
argue that our friendship is that a weak
point right now but in the macro forever
right we're just busy you guys should
work on well he was my act when Xander
was born and he was my admin and like
like we were playing tennis all the time
like I'm very mad at Nate because he's
gotten very Benton he has gotten very
into his girlfriend and very serious
back into golf Oh which doesn't allow me
to penetrate my wants and heats of what
he should be into which right now our
sports car like all right I know I hate
[ __ ] yeah but I'm naturally great at
it I think or at least they tells me I
could be good at it I believe him
because I prefer good hand-eye
coordination eyes and chips I'm a gym
class I want Nate to be in the sport
cards and the jab and he's now right now
he's in the Gulf and his girlfriend by
the way this was a good part and the
business I thought that he wines and it
was a little bit boring right now he's
loving it he loves got bug lis
Nate should be a professional golf all
right Nate lets me actually we like Nate
Nate's a good nice a great time
yeah great time yeah yeah yeah you're
gonna chatted we for like an open wine
for us yeah he did we had fun with him
yeah like right about half great you
guys know I'm not jealous you guys hung
out with him for three minutes no we've
been here since we haven't where was I
going oh I love Nate going backwards
happy like Oh Nate is only sitting in
this room because when he was an intern
we went up to Vermont and played
volleyball and his ruggedness and sheer
will to win and like competitive spirit
and he's an intern and I'm on the other
side of the net and he doesn't give a
[ __ ]
yeah I like this kid hey we were asking
him before he's ever in ten years has he
ever come close to being fired he
doesn't think so do you I'm Nate no Phil
did fail hilar we both fell Tyler get
Tyler right now Tyler almost got fired
what did he do
Tyler you're gonna break Tyler's right
now get in here hop on the mic real
quick Tyler tell the story about the
time you almost got fired what's almost
been fired twice about the real [ __ ] I'm
not gonna [ __ ] just one real quick
Tyler becomes AJ my brother's admin yeah
the first day he's my Abbot before it I
need the community management yeah we
were responding for the Jets the first
day he's in my brother's inbox as an
admin for AJ cuz he switched from
community management the Jets sent an
email AJ
we'd like to talk to you about Tyler
Schmidt we'd like him removed from the
Jets account which was like the most
important thing in the frickin world
that was the first email I ever opened
ask AJ's assistant I've talked to him
maybe five times I walk in his office
I'm like what did you do Tyler I walked
in his office and said so that email
what he was like
it's about know what did you do wrong oh
that's raw prioritized incorrectly
you've learned but tell about when you
actually almost got fired yeah I really
only got fired when I was working for
him first time it's delicious tea one
sec I was on the verge of falling in
love with a very beautiful woman and
this is romantic
hey this isn't crazy my fault I'll add
color commentary
Tyler was batting so over his head and
didn't understand how to calibrate
and I got caught oh because I was not
doing much at all work-wise
cuz he was so incapable of calibrating
how he was batting so over his head and
he was like what's happening in my life
is the greatest beautiful yes good
package I appreciate that and we were
taking a piss which is so weird and I
looked at him and he looked at me and
we're like I think there's an issue
going on you've a problem yes and I was
like I do and I yeah I mean I what do I
say you looked and then we talked on the
phone one time and it was like look this
is kind of like huh you've got to make a
decision
No No thank God yeah he was he was
massively batting over his head never
gonna happen
I think so but I own the Rae Tyler a
little bit he's way more Charlie's like
then I think he's sneaky he's one of
those guys like the guy looks at me like
no way and they're like what how is he
getting these girls charmed you agree
John yeah no cuz it works the other way
right you see like like I don't know
like everybody can't like I don't know I
don't think I'm good at gauging god I'm
much better at gauging if a guy's
good-looking today than I did in my 20s
in my 20s I was super confused I'd be
like that's a really good-looking guy
I'm like he's terrible with girls and
but but personality really [ __ ] yeah
oh my god said earlier Mary's versus
hooking up is a very different game like
guy that's a 10 but it's like a dork or
like just super basic you might want to
hook up after a bottle of empathy wines
yes dating like what are you gonna do
and they become better people this is
where guys and girls are the same people
don't think so but guard like I always
tell like young guys are so funny
they're so confused by women and girls
like they don't realize the girls are
saying the same [ __ ] they're saying to
their guys sorry guys
yeah yeah we all are but girls like go
rogue like the girls conversations are
more [ __ ] gangster than guy Congress
oh yeah how do you know that cuz I'm
kind of girly okay yeah I can't but I
had like real girlfriend like I can
really have friends like I'm very girl
like like I'm a amantha Bynes romantic
comedy movie watcher like I like when I
had girlfriends like I wanted to watch
the rom-com when they did like I'm like
I'm pretty I'm emotional I called my
brain empathy guys not like [ __ ] kill
it all right Tyler get out of here keep
charming them keep adding already okay
so Tyler Roma's come fire yeah right
that all right Nate how do we have a
game oh how do we have a game well we
built a brand on mom shoes we've done so
many things we are on a live tour we go
all across North America we fill
theaters with women who come out we show
them a good time we touch their hearts
we touch their loins oh yeah we have
strippers we have fun because we give
women permission period I'm just
permission you are you are here you you
are a woman you are enough you are okay
and the fact we go all the way I think
we've done 70 cities and the women the
common theme is I I had to move
mountains to get out and so many women
do most one I do on their own and I
don't I can't speak because our
community is women but often they're
pulling the weight on the children the
house working full-time trying to manage
relationship friendships and they have
zero like we've had women who haven't
been out in seven years who make time to
come to our shows awesome
so our whole mission you're doing really
nicely that makes me really happy we
just are it's our job to make them feel
like they have permission to be
themselves that you are enough the way
you are notice I put a period of
permission yeah almost if you really
analyze everything I do I'm just looking
for permission
yeah I'm looking at Cree permission
looking to let kids not listen to their
parents yeah I'm looking for parents to
not overcompensate their kids I'm
looking for people to have permission to
be themselves yeah yeah yeah yeah well
I'm permission to know that if you if
you like
you're gonna be okay but if you're for
what you're gonna get out like what I
always say that yeah what what well yeah
what's gonna happen yeah our night is
our night our book our game everything
across the board is always like you do
it differently I do it differently but
at the end of the day we all love the
same and we all just love you the same
Mike c'mon
everyone's like I'm a bad mom cuz I do
that's this that in the other we created
a book and we created a game who gets
the judge real quick on this bad man
people judge the people judge themselves
most of course right like once and for
all just on the record while we're
hanging who gets the judge that you're a
bad mom who your mother because she did
a certain way your sister like your best
friend like judgment is [ __ ] poison I
know it when people ever try to start
talking to me about being a parent
within seconds I'm like cool I'm gonna
let you finish off I go I'm gonna let
you finish this thought and then I'm
gonna counter with my opinion on how
your parenting yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't know I'm a bad mom says who know
47 we are trying to squash that term
permanent cuz now it's become like
terminology I'm a bad mom but no you're
not a bad mom you are the mom you are
and that will change today
tomorrow it's a year from Lawrence put
together manifesting from insecurity
yeah 100% and that's why people are like
how can you to go and travel all the
time leave your kids do this do that how
do you not feel guilty and we're like
because we're confident in what we're
doing here yet we have we have a partner
because you grew up in a framework that
caused 100 to not give up yeah yeah yeah
yeah and we also don't apologize for a
way this is why I'm pushing parents to
let their kids fail us to for the you me
resilient you know and and let your kids
take risks so they can feel the what if
you like to be uncomfortable I've well
otherwise were raising [ __ ] Julian
also if you know but also as if you
think about it confidence and self
esteem is gained its earned it's not
given so you cannot give it to your kids
so what they want to do is funny though
or are you a blank state and what
happens is parents by showing their kids
that they don't believe in them
eliminate it yeah no it's a very
interesting you know it's it's one in
the same you're saying
I'm saying when you when that whole
scandal came out a couple weeks ago
where parents were buying their kids
into college yeah everybody went to
everybody rushed to like this is
terrible what about the kid that
deserved to get I went to the kid I go
oh that kid who knows that their parents
bought their way into college telling
their child you're such a [ __ ] loser I
so don't believe it yeah yeah that I
have to buy like it's that kids finished
yeah the kid that was trying to get into
Yale and now is going to Michigan State
and knows they deserve it that kid has a
[ __ ] chip on her shoulder like the
three of us yeah it's gonna [ __ ] kill
the world yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well
we also say you yet parenting has to be
uncomfortable like you can't make it
comfortable because your kids have to
earn the feelings because it's only
gonna get bigger as they get older so
they can't handle the little feelings
there's not gonna help with parenting
make people are parenting to have other
people judge them not for their kids the
parenting out of the what the other
parents are gonna say yeah yeah I can't
wait I can't wait for what for what some
parent to come up to me so look my
oldest isn't about to be 10 so what that
means is those kids and I see it already
when I come to school those kids are
starting to get on Instagram well when
they get on Instagram they're gonna
stumble across the father of the kid
who's yelling on [ __ ] your parents yeah
I feel like I'm only 36 months away from
getting somebody calling me and saying
mr. Vaynerchuk yes this is mr. Thompson
Hyatt my son is in your daughter's grade
I'm like mr. Thompson how are you listen
I have a real problem I like [ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah I have a problem
till you keep a stop because you'll be
my contact yeah yeah we see that we [ __ ]
are you talking about what a proble
always asked I know you have a problem
what [ __ ] wasting your time by
calling me yeah like people come just
like what are your Ryan's gonna think
later when they watch this content they
see the things you're saying I don't
think my mom was a [ __ ] bad-ass act
and that's the bullying [ __ ] you know
what every kid I get DTM's you know yeah
hits think of parents that live fake
lives that their parents are full of
[ __ ] they have no respect yeah yeah we
actually have a ton of teenagers who
follow us because they shouldn't see
what is happily and I'm
Facebook you to excuse me Facebook you
to put your phone number
because we're gonna try to sneak in a
couple of calls way too much fun with
the ladies but like we need to get some
calls in its going fast it's it's going
fast because this is the greatest show
you've ever been on exactly except for
our own but anyway where you can find us
you know we're kind of in a way the
female version of you because we are
unexpected unexpected rogues I love that
you know I mean you think I don't know
what that about us you see us and you're
like no I thought that about you when I
saw you oh look at your faces said these
ladies are crazy want to say [ __ ] go
okay but I know it's 2019 yeah I know
you'd love just lean over catnap yeah
you say this [ __ ] about what's gonna
happen when our kids friends and their
parents find out about everything that
we're saying and doing is we are now
preparing the dialogue not only for
husbands telling our children but I was
telling our children that what we're
doing is a good thing and then you
should be proud of us no matter what
anyone else says and so we're constantly
saying that because you're prepared a
dialogue we more insular thus you're
gonna make your world and so me too yeah
yeah be proud of that you know that's
good you know what that's gonna do it's
gonna be the greatest thing I ever
happened to your kids yes they're not
gonna be peer pressure but you guys this
is the you were doing the greatest thing
for your children ever I believe it it's
so much I can imagine
I mean yeah I I agree and I think that
if you are a parent who is struggling
I'm like stop looking at parents and
advice and go find who you are in order
to like we're so passionate about
motherhood and helping women feel like
they're not alone and not isolated like
if the amount of women that have come up
to us and have said you know I was I was
close to killing myself is actually off
the charts every yeah everybody yeah
yeah right when you're the truth when
you're pure when you're a hundred yeah
this is what you get yeah yeah but we
take that we honor that and we ownership
and we the world thinks we're rogen
crazy we're doing the right thing
they're doing the wrong no yeah no I
agree with you but what you can live
that truth every day with your kids with
your with your with your everything that
you do but it starts with you yeah
you're insecure and you care what the
Alpha PTA mom's gonna think of you
really are everything that's what mr.
Thompson I can't wait for you to call me
all right as you can tell
I know you have a prophet my god you can
speak [ __ ] problem I have a matter of
fact I'm now gonna make a video I'm the
next day when when mr. Thompson calls me
in 3 years
the next thing my video is gonna be like
hey Ricky Thompson this videos for you
hey your dad's a dick yeah be it's ok
I'll help you yes I'm not a [ __ ] coup
d'etat Thompson's household yeah look it
up so good Lindsay it's Gary B hey Gary
Vee you're with the moms that are so
full of truth it makes me uncomfortable
oh I met them in Morristown and they are
we did a show yeah they better say that
one wants to be Jersey girls are [ __ ] I
was amazing that was Lydia's [ __ ] right
yeah it was it was so much fun
I don't know if you guys remember me I
had the the nude fur vest on I'm glad we
wouldn't forget your fur vest I wanted
to rip it off your back you actually
said that you said it was so Jersey and
you loved it I'm a fan of both of you
guys my husband is a huge guy you can
I'm a huge cat man this is a great
[ __ ] family there we go and your
family's clearly winning life so my
question is I'm a new station home home
and I'm just kind of like strong I'm a
hard worker but I'm kind of struggling
right now to find like my thing and I
know Gary always like contact contact
Cranston and I'm all about it but what
if you don't know exactly what you
wanted well it's better to make
something and try to figure it out then
play in your head and never do anything
the reason I'm saying content like most
people don't know but the way to find
out is to taste right like like I always
think of it in food terms like I'm like
I always do this like when I go out I'm
like you I love oysters I'm like you
want some oysters like oh I hate oysters
8 out of 10 people when they say they
hate oysters have never had one yeah
yeah life you don't of course you don't
know what you like or what you're
passionate about or what have you but
the only way for you to know is to try
comparable we just back throughout the
reason you know everything that we just
talked about for the last five minutes
is about self-esteem yeah if you're
willing to make a video of you cooking
even though you don't know how or you
think you're great at it or whatever
maybe if you're willing to make a video
about your thoughts on Parenthood ten
years in if you're willing to review
whine like I did if you're willing to do
a hot take like Stephen a Smith if you
have a point of view on where Yanis is
ranking in the top five players in the
world right now
that's a scary piece of content if you
never put out sports content in the
world but if you actually secretly love
the [ __ ] MBA and have a hot take on
deer and foxes upside over the next five
years you could go on to become Erin
Andrews you just don't know people don't
know until they do and so the reason I
keep saying content content content is
that's the answer but it starts heavier
it starts a level up which is you have
to give yourself permission huh to be
willing to put your content and when you
post a video of you're hot take on the
Raptors winning two games in a row are
you ready for 11 or 12 of your best
friends saying what the [ __ ] are you
doing that was like yeah her and I don't
know what the [ __ ] we're doing 90
percent of the time but it doesn't stop
us from doing it we show up a hundred
percent and we go and sometimes it fails
and sometimes sometimes we fail it
sometimes we nail it but the people love
watching when we fail it when we nail it
cuz it's awesome and you know what we
just you know we don't think maybe you
just jump in but just jump and try
something and it's okay to change your
mind if you put something out tomorrow
and then you decide that didn't actually
work I want to try something different
don't be afraid we have changed so many
times over okay and here's the key the
key to all of this is what's the
alternative what are you gonna live your
whole life saying what's my passion yeah
yeah I mean like what's the downside
like you're talking to three people here
who've completely had upside with
knowing that the only uniqueness we had
was the being 100% ourselves we live in
a world now where everybody can be a
personality right so what happens that
means there's a supply that we've never
seen before where do you actually create
uniqueness you create uniqueness in
being 100% your pure self because if
you're 80
then you look like everything else where
and Lindsay if you have the lady balls
to wear that fur vest to our show you
have the gall to job yeah yeah yeah you
got this yeah and there's a real tight
real quick real quick ones the question
is you probably felt comfortable wearing
that in the environment of the safety of
the four walls created by right the
truth right yeah the question becomes
are you then willing to do that outside
that box
I think we're it was my first night out
postpartum so I like well my hair I put
on a new outfit and I had the best out
of my life and we were asked backwards
and we only have to do it because not
because not because someone's like you
should keep doing it and come to another
show it's better now it's better I
definitely want to go to another so
other and also I was the one on your
live yesterday and said the last one
thank you so much I'm later I love you
guys thank you kiss for being a Gary Vee
family has a fun yeah he was like you've
got to watch this guy he's amazing he
looks at you all the time and I was
gonna cry I'm at so this is like our
perfect company's greatest show ever
hurtled ever when you have the courage
to be judged
maybe the three of us are yeah what
people understand is for when the
establishment judges me and they always
do and always will and always have what
what the establishment doesn't
understand is we get those message yeah
I love when the elite ideological
classic judge me look Gary like I get a
lot of it especially now as I can
continue to get build momentum and I
laugh and I'm like you think you're such
a great person yeah and you're a great
person in your insular world yes
yeah being in your [ __ ] ivory tower
I'm in the [ __ ] trenches with people
yep I'm getting kids that are 17
who are taking photos about [ __ ]
rifle yeah and posting that this was in
my mouth an hour ago I watched her video
yeah so like I'm very glad that you
[ __ ] went to Yale and that you write
up ends for the [ __ ] war times but I
live in real [ __ ] world yeah yeah but
and that's people who create content for
Instagram rather people who create
content for their community and it
doesn't matter how many people you have
it's the people that you actually invest
in which is your to stop looking
outwards look to them hey did you try to
get back to you soon as possible think
she's on message we leave our message at
the tone please record your message
when you're finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
faith you made the biggest mistake of
your life you put your phone number in
and I and here we are
we called you yeah we were out there we
wanted to be with you yeah we did
would've been something you've
remembered forever yeah and guess what
happened you weren't there weren't there
and guess what if you do what everybody
does on this show you're gonna call back
in a minute
mm-hmm and guess what we're not pick it
up yeah you missed it ramifications yeah
it's like the four of us yeah yeah y'all
really lived with ramifications but if I
was her I'd call her 700 times I got
three I guess what doors babe we are not
answering thank you oh my god I mean I
feel like there's a year we could go on
but honestly just uh I I think that
everybody's everybody's gotta listen to
you
and honestly we wrote the book that we
wrote mom truce and that's another thing
is it when they're like oh you're you're
doing so well you've sold on this many
books you're a best seller yeah we're
like oh you guys seem way more excited
than we do we wrote a books just so we
can be called an author just because it
mattered to you what matters to us is
our audience and our people but we wrote
the book because we needed to have a
book that moms what was real for moms
and ones they should be delivered when
they leave the hospital no parenting
books but this is the real deal
good for you hello hello it's Gary
Vaynerchuk in your own patent that on
the askgaryvee show
oh my goodness you're gonna wake up in a
minute I never thought this would have
happened my favorite I mean honestly I'm
from Georgia
and I've never heard of you I just
thought they were going to be on your
show just being honest so that's why I
was watching real quick you never heard
of me Gary or the ladies
yes of you I appreciate it fair enough
but you're quickly realizing you don't
love me right no I mean I like you now
there's I've been watching this so that
all you know this this segment right
thank you yeah oh he's really up about
if I can get a phone call so when the
millionaires can you ladies answer for
you
I was asking when is the captain that
cruise okay so when is the cruise Wow we
aren't we aren't we're working on it
[Music]
no I did a wine cruise oh you know
everything when's the crew soccer
partner I have a great one yeah because
I remember when y'all said we're going
to a fun show and then fun so came and
yeah and I was yeah I'm to the Atlantis
show back in September and it was one of
the best what not one of the best nights
of my entire adult life thank you so
much and we got you we hear you we hear
the people we listen to you it's going
to happen in the meantime come to Vegas
and remember yeah Vegas in September my
yeah girl your biggest crazy
yeah what we can get yeah no Vegas is
like Vegas can handle y'all you've never
been to Vegas taking her in Styles you
can see oh my never been to Vegas I've
taken we're doing things Kay we're doing
guy Molly we're doing you so there's
still time we're doing life last one Wow
that was pretty funny
yeah me too
that's that if you guys create an
ecosystem of no nerves
yeah they feel comfortable to us there
where there are people hey now how many
selfies do you take a day not many good
we do a lot in stories understand I'm
talking about like when you're out about
do people roll up on you oh you know we
have a naughty podcast a really naughty
podcast that's great it's like off the
rails not what should be it's a business
one with a little bit of sex which is
not good an intent lot of said late it's
not sexy hello Jose what's up you're on
the askgaryvee show with cottonmouths no
[ __ ] yeah oh you put a [ __ ] phone
number in a we call it happened Julie oh
my god can have you changed my life you
laser amazing I have one question
my wife doesn't support me in my
entrepreneurship goals why she's redone
because we want to move to Florida and I
don't think we should move unless we
have a nice amount of a nice sum of
money to go and I think flipping houses
and as well Gary our trash talk for
amazing I started flipping things on
myself and I have to tell you this Gary
I bought ink cartridge for a dollar I
bought two of them I saw them for 154
hours the next day let's [ __ ] go yeah
the next day Gary me do you think you're
surprising me I know what the [ __ ] this
is I've been doing it for 20 [ __ ]
years I'm just gonna put you on yeah I
got so I just went out this past weekend
went through awesome anyway my wife's
don't support me she doesn't believe in
my goals and dreams we've been together
19 years we have five kids I don't know
how to go about it I'm nervous
it's brother you over communicate
let her know how it feels when she
shoots you down but this is the things
ladies I don't mean to cut you off
um years ago before we bought I bought a
home I paid it off she used to help me
clean our houses abandoned house and
used to gets hazed together you know
what I mean so I think she just lost I
think she lost the drive and the love
for it like she gets down in 30 she gets
cleaning she does the higher things she
moves furniture with me trash and
creeping and I guess over the year she
lost the loafers dude she's man she's
the mother of five Charlie Brown
yeah I'm the father of five children til
dude I was doing 90% of it when I was
about saying up I was gonna singing up
all the nights over tonight getting on
taking care of the kids threw up and I
guess getting up in two out of the three
going to where it's coming back home
listen cooking cleaning dude dude my mom
died at 16 before she died she taught me
how to cook from another cleaning so we
had new laundry tell me everything not
to depend on the woman to rely on myself
and I the best thing that she ever
taught me respect mother he's out and
see so prospective cuz there's always
two sides of a story but from one
perspective keep giving us context what
do you think's happen
you think she's become entitled you
think she won't like what's tired what
has happened I spoiled her with
everything with the cooking the cleaning
the taking care of the kids the home the
hanging out with the kids picking them
up and to be honest you guys and you
know I hope you don't do it but she
likes to sit there not lately and spend
three hours watching reality shows on
her phone on YouTube and it drives me
crazy and then Gary check this out Gary
I'm on your arm on your level I don't
want my kids go to college I'm trying to
open their idea to them charming
entrepreneurs go go go go
I don't want my kids to go to college if
they don't want to go to college
like if my kids want to be the greatest
professor in a university of all time
and that's in their soul I will support
the [ __ ] out of totally yeah I don't
want to force them like forcing them but
real quick but real quick I just want to
make sure that people know where I stand
on this stuff it's I just want
self-awareness and Liang into children
right so out of five kids two of them
are gonna want to go to college
two more not gonna go to college and one
is gonna be in the middle you don't what
I mean so keep that in mind
no absolutely but before they start like
not eighteen and nineteen but I was
doing at sixteen seventeen and saying
hey guys
try the eBay or try this or my second
oldest you want to be an architect come
to find out she denied a job at an
architecture student she did not an
internship at alpha toy company because
she only spoke to my wife and my wife
said no don't take it
ila dad that's a great opportunity for
you to learn him and I even told her I'm
gonna build a home I want you to build
it for me
and that's not working for me she's like
going her own route the same thing my 19
year old I'm like hey you you have
business plans of being an entrepreneur
unfortunately Gary I'm doing pay you
guys you want it the time out I'm here
for you would you sit down together go
over YouTube videos whatever you wanna
do you wanna stop together and I know
you guys gotta go
my son is 16 years old he wanted to be
an actor
and he wants to be a producer so I left
him hey let's sit down together you're
watching videos on e I'm here to help
you he didn't want to do it I go up to
one day I say hey buddy
do you want me to stop asking you what
you won't do with your life because I'm
here to help you he goes yeah stop
asking me I'm like you sure like what
what else can I do I'm not forcing on
them I'm bilingual I'm Spanish I tell
them hey you guys take the time out
learn Spanish I'm here to help you it's
for free Gary I spent so much of your
[ __ ] knowledge I have my children
it's [ __ ] crazy and they're not
taking it or not gonna be the father I'm
not gonna be the dog you did it's just a
[ __ ] down and you know [ __ ] to her
Spanish or you the [ __ ] no I'm not gonna
do that just gonna come back to me down
the line exactly I'm not gonna so I'm
just trying to open your eyes to like
hey look at this video of Gary Vee look
he's doing oh yeah he's a millionaire
but listen that goal that boom said he
still have the drive to go girl
so you guys don't you see that like you
can do it too and I told God okay I sit
there I've got three three cells arm
breaking our break across fish all these
guys rock star Bradley Beach and I sit
down and I watched it are they fun
they're not fun Gary but I'm learning
I'm [ __ ] learning I'm trying to show
them this but they're not getting it and
neither is my wife like let's make these
moves like really have a hump that date
between a house fire real quick
deploying ambition is a very fascinating
game what you're trying to do is deploy
ambition and I respect that and I love
you for it I there's so much good but
when you give you can't have expectation
even when it's your own children what
you're doing is right but you can't
enforce the next part right like you
start and you said something very smart
at your heat moment which is I'm not
gonna be the dad that's gonna [ __ ]
sit them down and say you have to cuz
it's gonna be right yes so you're
extremely thoughtful about this I think
if you take a little bit of the ideology
out of look they're sixteen your
circumstance was your mom passed at that
time you learned all these things yeah
you've thank God through whatever
success you've created you've created a
level of entitlement and a level of cush
for your kids and as much as that hurts
and listen bro you're talking to me
[ __ ] like the Delta between my
life and my siblings life let alone my
[ __ ] kids life is [ __ ] never easy
you're sitting right now with two women
who [ __ ] [ __ ] she was in high school
[ __ ] delivering papers rolling
[ __ ] alright like I put the beginning
of it your life's gonna be like what her
kids life excuse me is when they [ __ ]
have a hockey player dad and a [ __ ]
mom that's making millions like what
what guess this is what everybody
struggles right however all three of us
all four of us excuse me have to take a
big step back you've got to separate and
it's very important you've got to
separate your issues of non
communication
two totally different places that you
and your wife are from you and your kids
sell early you've that's number one
because a lot of that angst is deploying
on their kids number two it's amazing
that you're spitting it but you gotta
spit it and then take a step back
spit it and take a step back don't
forget your 16 year old can be 28 when
it clicks for him yeah and then he has
his whole life to make it awesome so
keep that a little bit of mine the
bigger thing a nice boy that's it then
put a period over like like with the
working out like my son told me one day
hey you know that I see working out and
running and Gary I'm also fast in 16
hours a day too buddy
anyway I found he tells me hey I want to
work out so I said hey I'm not gonna
call you buddy you asked me tomorrow you
come to me we'll sit down we'll go all
the beginning workouts I have to start
and everything I will take it from there
yeah dad cool next day came I'm cleaning
I'm cooking I'm helping my other son
with his homework he doesn't come down
he's not I'm not gonna say Josh because
I've been doing it for so long hey Josh
come valuate start doing this he sure
had the drives himself I don't want to
keep our me being cake you know remind
him to be not mean I mean you would
think within yourself you're gonna find
that drive and yeah yeah yeah
ya know jumping in the falling down ski
I see a lot of modern parents thinking
falling down is a skinned knee and I
think falling down is your arm being
ripped off and in that Delta is a very
interesting debate yeah like it's so
important to be let them let them talk
to you let me ask you a question let me
ask you a question
go go go do you give these children
money no don't [ __ ] [ __ ] me do
let's do the parents get on hold on my
two oldest eighteen and nineteen girls
they work at Target my 16 year old son
he works for my wife boss like he goes
to his house and does them lon yep my
but my 12 year old daughter she has a
babysitting gig my wife girlfriend job
so for daughter my 12 you will watch the
trip and then my nine-year-old son I
mean he's nine pick up the shoes no give
them money no what do know what what
entitlement do they have in your opinion
I don't know what I mean you mean like
an example what do you mean by that why
do you think they're soft because I'm
spitting ten minute a little minutes
that everyone's soft which is amazing I
think everyone's soft too but I'm
curious what your perspective is like
there were babies there were babies I
was doing the laundry
what do you lunch I'll do a few I'll
cook for you I'll come for you I'll do
this for you and over the years like the
other day dude like you know it is what
it is I go upstairs the the bathroom who
thirty like you guys like I've been
cleaning it for you guys for how long
and it's like one year out the other and
I'm like I might as well just do it
myself
you quickly a spoiled child is actually
not monetary a spoiled child is someone
who gets given or it gets fixed for so
let's say they're having a problem the
parent steps in and fix it support them
this bathroom is dirty it has spoiled as
nothing to do with monetary and a lot of
people are like they're spoiled they get
you can actually have but also have an
unspoiled child by letting them
experience life so if their bathrooms
dirty natural [ __ ] consequence it's
dirty
they have to piss on it and that's that
that's that's the way it goes it's it's
letting them understand that their their
life has consequences but you've been
doing it for them forever Jose yeah and
the reason they're not about why that's
you know that's on you yep don't ya the
part of asking and purpose that you need
you to stop Paulina
you're up to showering it dude it's this
is on you bro yeah you told the story
just now you know it all Jose hold on
you know you told the story that you
cleaned it you cleaned it you cleaned it
clean it they don't know how yeah and
then you say [ __ ] I'll just clean it
that last part is why you're losing no
I'm 41 I'm having young if you're a
[ __ ] you're 100 never clean the look
in the bro
Jose around me I love you I love you go
never calling the [ __ ] bathroom again
dawg
never you know what I know it's crazy
listen to me my my wife is she tells me
and I have a bad habit of it she was
honey stop letting the kids ruin our
night and they almost did it again last
night because she's cuz I run up there
we really both went up and she slipped
out a little bit but I was flipping now
and she said no no no let's go
downstairs I want to watch the movie
don't let this room get night you've
been and I almost did I almost went back
upstairs you can bet so you know what
she's she's right she's not sit down
you're only for the movie the upside and
he had a good car move you saw bro stop
cleaning the [ __ ]
[ __ ] bathroom no I was just read
write do say what it swivels and rocked
in New York email me your address I'm
gonna [ __ ] spy on your ass and if you
ever [ __ ] clean the [ __ ] go go go
brother Sammy you're doing such a cliche
thing yeah you're trying to control
everything and then you're complaining
about it yeah either clean the bathroom
and shut the [ __ ] up yeah or never clean
the bathroom again and it'll be like one
more time either I'm like [ __ ] I'm
saying they sued you like you value
listen to me either I love you Gary good
Lots already either options either a
clean the [ __ ] up or B never clean the
[ __ ] bathroom again all right at some
point listen to it what is your question
of the day okay this is our beef right
now yeah is is authentic something you
are or is it something everyone's trying
to be interesting
well we're about to see the answers
katnappe mom's a [ __ ] truth what tell
me tell me I want to make sure I have a
funny feeling I'm like wow there's a you
were about to grow your dude fanbase
because you guys are at me and I'm you
yeah so please tell everybody books
games what do you guys for some right
hooks catnap everywhere I'm Matt Baume
hey they did someone owns [ __ ] dog
step the [ __ ] up and buy it
okay fair you cannot defeat
step up and buy it you guys are building
real brown yeah I know we are and then
let the squatter make a couple bucks
[ __ ] see hey really that bad yes see
I can do doesn't mean anything
all right got it got everybody talking
okay and then mom truths is everywhere
we are we gave our live shows you can
get all the tickets a catnap or dudes
allowed oh they love it rippers well man
strippers but do just oh it's man
strippers suck you hate women Jews but
you know what we have that men are like
I had would they come with their wives
and they're like that's the first what
are we doing you're 17 whines like the
official whine of these ladies now right
hell yeah what were you trying to
[ __ ] steal money from my guys no no
we're not we haven't even talked we just
got drunk with your 8 that's all we know
and you know what if they don't sell it
in the theater we can give it yeah we
can't well anyways we got lots of ideas
just come at night and home very we got
this it's with the C not a K like a
kitty cat yeah thank you guys thank you
thank you keep asking questions we'll
keep answering them
on this episode all hell breaks loose
[Music]
for that call to end with jose saying
yesterday I did not see Joe Namath's
question day being about abortion